Tout est prêt à Washington.
Le président Donald Trump
s'apprête à prononcer
son deuxième discours
sur l'état de l'Union.
Un discours reporté
d'une semaine en raison
de l'impasse budgétaire
qui a paralysé le gouvernement
pendant 35 jours.
Mesdames et Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale. C'est dans un contexte
de division que Donald Trump
va s'adresser aux deux Chambres
du Congrès réunies.
La trêve budgétaire prend fin
dans 10 jours à Washington
et le financement du mur
continue de déchirer démocrates
et républicains.
Avec moi, pour cette émission,
Karine Prémont, professeure
agrégée à l'École de politique
appliquée de l'Université
de Sherbrooke; John Parisella,
professeur invité au Centre
d'études et de recherches
internationales de l'Université
de Montréal. Et à Washington,
notre correspondant Christian
Latreille.
Bonsoir. Je vais commencer avec
vous parce que c'est toujours un
moment solennel, entendu,
particulièrement cette année,
Christian, parce que le
président a dû attendre la
volonté de Nancy Pelosi pourrait
éviter à la chambre des
représentants dans un contexte
très grande tension. Déjà,
certains extraits filtrent comme
le veut la tradition. Qu'est-ce
qu'on en sait maintenant?
- Certains dise même que
Monsieur Trump a mis fin à la
fermeture par cette gouvernement
justement prêt en mesure de
respecter cette tradition et
d'avoir l'occasion de s'adresser
à des millions d'Américains qui
vont l'écouter ce soir. Vous
avez raison, il y a quelques
extraits qui ont commencé à
filtrer du discours de Monsieur
Trump. On prévoit un discours
d'environ 45 minutes. L'année
dernière, ça avait été 80
minutes. On verra bien de quelle
manière et à quel rythme Donald
Trump lira le disco. Ce qu'on
peut voir jusqu'à maintenant,
c'est que Monsieur Trump veut
tenter comme il avait fait
d'ailleurs l'année dernière, il
peut tenter, tendre la main aux
Américains, tendre la main aux
démocrates également et se faire
en sorte, il veut unir, c'est ce
qu'il mentionne dans les lignes
qui nous ont été rendues
disponibles. Il veut faire en
sorte de penser les vieilles
blessures, de mettre fin aux
vieilles querelles qui divisent
la classe politique américaine à
Washington.
Il mentionne également, il
revient sur ses réussites entre
autres sa réforme de la justice
criminelle aux États-Unis.
Il veut également s'attaquer au
prix des médicaments qui coûtent
très cher aux Américains, qui
est un des pays où les
médicaments coûtent le plus
cher.
Il sera question de
infrastructures aussi, question
des migrations, il veut
absolument que ce problème soit
réglé afin de passer à autre
chose. On sait qu'il y a
plusieurs présidents qui se sont
cassés les dents au cours de
dernière génération à tenter de
régler le problème de
l'immigration. Bien sûr, ce
n'est pas écrit dans les lignes
qui ont été rendues publiques
jusqu'à maintenant, mais c'est
certainement, Monsieur Trump va
passer le message très clair
qu'il veut ce mur, il y tient
absolument. De quelle manière il
va s'y prendre? On verra bien.
Mais la grande différence soir,
c'est que le congrès,
le contrôle du congrès est
maintenant partagé. Vous verrez
dans la chambre. Vous verrez
Nancy Pelosi qui pour la
deuxième fois devient la leader
de la chambre et ce sera
intéressant de lire le langage
corporel de tous et chacun ce
soir pour voir un peu comment ça
va se passer.
- D'autres membres du congrès
arrivent. On voit Madame Pelosi
pendant que vous parlez à côté
du vice président. Christian, le
discours de Monsieur Trump
l'année dernière, c'était 5839
mots mais ça s'est terminé à 22
heures 17.
C'était beaucoup plus long
qu'annoncé. On verra si ce sera
le cas ce soir. On est là pour
le couvrir intégralement, ce
discours, surveiller à quel
moment il sera applaudi, sur
quel thème, s'il réussira à se
faire applaudir par les
démocrates. On a vu l'arrivée de
Madame Trump entouré des invités
de la Maison-Blanche. J'aimerais
qu'on dise un petit mot là-
dessus avant de continuer son
importance disco. On peut
toujours passer des messages à
travers les invitations que l'on
fait à certaines personnes qui
ont marqué l'actualité
américaine.
- D'un côté comme de l'autre
d'ailleurs. Les démocrates ont
droit invité, le président et
les républicains ont droit à
leur invité également. Monsieur
Trump qui a invité un dénommé
Alice qui a passé de nombreuses
années en prison pour une
transaction de drogue, un crime
sans violence. On sait que la
réforme qui est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre démocrates
et républicains, cette réforme
sur la justice criminelle aux
États-Unis, va faire en sorte
que je sors de situation se
produise beaucoup moins souvent.
Les démocrates de leur côté ont
invité cette dame, rappelez-vous
lorsque Jeff Flake avait été un
interpellé au moment où il avait
prie l'ascenseur lorsqu'on
étudiait sa candidature, cette
femme avait vraiment interpellé
cet homme en disant : écoutait,
vous devez absolument refuser ce
poste à Monsieur Cavanna. Cette
personne sera là. Elle a été
invitée d'une nouvelle démocrate
qui brasse beaucoup en ce moment
à Washington.
- On voit la grande patronne de
la CIA, contredite par Monsieur
Trump.
- Et le président d'EDI, le
département d'intelligence
nationale.
Le procureur par intérim.
- Monsieur Pompeo.
- Il est controversé parce qu'il
avait fait des propos contre
l'enquête de Monsieur Molères.
Il est sous surveillance. Il
pourrait être même l'objet de
surveillance par la chambre de
représentants pour d'autres
questions.
Ils ont tous peur que ce soit
lui lorsque Mueller va déposer
son rapport. Il y a beaucoup de
démocrates qui s'inquiètent de
cela. Même les républicains qui
s'inquiètent de cela. Il y en a
qui se dise victimes, disons, de
scandale.
- Monsieur Trump, dans son
entrevue à CBS en fin de semaine
avant le Super Bowl avait laissé
entendre qu'il n'était pas
certain si tout le rapport
serait rendu public.
- Ce n'est pas lui qui va
décider. C'est pour ça que c'est
important de savoir ce qu'il va
faire. On peut imaginer que
certains membres du congrès
démocrate, même dans l'équipe de
Mueller pourrait faire des
fuites sur ce rapport.
- Je pense que le rapport est
rendu à un point que c'est un
incontournable. Les gens
s'attendent à cela.
Puis, c'est quand même une
enquête qui dure depuis plus de
deux ans. Ça semble être assez
méthodique dans la façon qu'il a
faite. Il y a quand même des
accusations, des gens qui ont
plaidé coupable. Il y a des
arrestations et des enquêtes qui
se font à d'autres niveaux,
l'État de New York fait des
enquêtes aussi. En plus de ça,
il y a le congrès qui va
commencer des enquêtes sur les
rapports d'impôt de Monsieur
Trump.
- La caméra qui est sur Madame
Trump et il y a le petit garçon
Joshua Trump qui est la parce
qu'il serait intimidé parce
qu'il est un Trump.
Le président devrait arriver
dans quelques minutes. Je crois
qu'on fait l'appel du président.
(applaudissements)
Il fait son entrée.
Christian, quelle est
l'importance du discours de
Monsieur Trump?
- Je pense que c'est un discours
très important, Anne-Marie, pour
Monsieur Trump parce qu'il sort
quand même d'une période
difficile. Ce que vient de lui
faire vivre Nancy Pelosi en lui
refusant le financement de son
mur et surtout en le des
invitant ou en lui refusant
l'accès au Congrès pour ce
fameux discours sur l'état de
l'union, ça a été extrêmement
difficile pour Monsieur Trump.
Je pense que c'est rarement
arrivé qu'un président se fasse
refuser un discours sur l'état
de l'union. Il a perdu cette
bataille contre Madame Pelosi.
Ce soir, ce sera l'occasion pour
Monsieur Trump de se reprendre
et de réitérer sa volonté
de vouloir unir les Américains.
On sait que l'année dernière, ça
n'avait pas duré longtemps. Il
n'est pas le genre de président,
le genre de personnalité qui va
facilement unir les Américains.
Il est divise plutôt. Il divise
politiquement. Les États-Unis
n'ont jamais été aussi divisés
comme société. Il y a des
familles et des gens qui n'osent
plus parler de politique.
Comment est-ce qu'il va faire
pour tenter d'unir ce pays qui
n'a jamais été aussi écartelé?
Donc, ce sera intéressant de le
suivre. Il y a certainement des
terrains d'attente vous savait
comme les infrastructures, le
prix des médicaments, ce sont
de sujets, ce sont des items sur
lesquels il peut s'entend avec
les démocrates. Alors, on verra
la collaboration qui naîtra
entre Madame Pelosi ou naîtra
pas entre Madame Pelosi et
Monsieur Trump. Ce soir, ce sera
l'occasion de voir aussi et
c'est important, comment il va
souligner également la présence
de Madame Pelosi. En 2007,
George Bush avait eu la
délicatesse, a été très
gentlemen en disant :
je suis très honoré de dire pour
la première fois Madame
Hallyday. Je crois que les yeux
sont rivés ce soir sur Donald
Trump pour voir de quelle
manière il accueillera Nancy
Pelosi qui historiquement
devient...
- Il arrive devant le podium.
Rappelez-nous pourquoi beaucoup
de gens sont en blanc?
- C'est le centième anniversaire
du droit de vote des
américaines.
Deux dures luttes. Les femmes en
blanc, ce soir, c'est un peu
cela que l'on veut
- Il se présente. On peut
imaginer qu'il va prendre la
parole d'un moment à l'autre. On
va l'écouter.
On va parler de ce discours par
après avec nos invités.
On a hâte si cet appel est
crédible, s'il sort de son Tech,
on ne sait jamais. Ce sont des
choses qui peuvent arriver.
Monsieur Pence qui est le vice-
président.
Pas trop chaleureux, c'était
correct.
- Ils se sont serrés la main,
c'est bien.
- Je ne suis pas sûr que c'est
une bonne décision mais il va le
faire.
On n'a pas vu beaucoup de gens
qui se sont forcés dans la prise
de photos.
- Ça a été bref.
- Les invités, c'est clair
qu'ils sont très thématiques.
On parle de thèmes.
- Du côté des républicains, des
gens victimes d'immigrants
illégaux, du côté de Madame
Pelosi, des gens qui sont
victimes de la paralysie, de
transgenres également.
On va écouter Monsieur Trump.
Bon discours, Mesdames et
Messieurs. Rester à l'écoute. On
se retrouve tantôt.
- Monsieur le vice président,
membres du congrès...
(applaudissements)
première dame des États-Unis...
Et mes chers compatriotes.
Le moment en est un de potentiel
illimité. À mesure que c'est un
nouveau congrès, je suis devant
vous prêt à travailler afin
orchestré de percée historique
pour tous les Américains.
Des milliers de nos concitoyens
nous regardent, nous écoutent,
dans cette grande assemblée
espérant que nous allons
gouverner non pas comme deux
parties mais comme une seule
nation.
(applaudissements)
Les priorités que j'aimerais
vous présenter, ce ne sont pas
des priorités républicaines ou
démocrates.
Ce sont les priorités du peuple
américain.
Beaucoup d'entre nous avons
faite campagne sur les mains
promesse de base, défendre
l'emploi américain est demandé
du commerce équitable pour les
travailleurs américains.
Rebâtir et revitaliser notre
infrastructure nationale,
réduire le prix de soins de
santé et de médicaments
prescrits, d'en arriver à un
système d'immigration qui est
sécuritaire, qui est légale,
moderne et qui assure la
sécurité de tous et chacun. Et
d'en arriver à une politique
étrangère qui met nos intérêts,
en fait, les intérêts de
l'Amérique au tout premier plan.
Il y a une occasion qui se
présente à nous et il nous faut
faire preuve de courage pour
saisir cette occasion historique
qui se présente à nous.
(applaudissements)
La victoire, ce n'est pas de
gagner pour notre parti, la
victoire, c'est de gagner pour
notre pays.
(applaudissements)
Cette année, l'Amérique va
reconnaître deux anniversaires
importants qui nous montrent la
majesté de la mission de
l'Amérique et le pouvoir de cet
orgueil national. Au moins de
juin, il y avait déjà 75 ans,
ce que le général a appelé la
grande croisade.
La libération par les alliés de
l'Europe lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale.
(applaudissements)
Et donc, le jour D, le 6 juin
le 6 juin 1944, 15 000 jeunes
Américains ont sauté du ciel et
60 000 se sont présentés par
voie maritime avant de sauver
notre civilisation de la
tyrannie.
Ici, ce soir avec nous, il y a
trois d'entre eux,
trois de ces héros incroyables.
(...)
(applaudissements)
Messieurs, nous vous saluons.
En 2019, nous célébrons
également le cinquantenaire
quand de jeunes pilotes
ont traversé 250 000 milles à
travers l'espace pour planter
notre drapeau sur la surface
lunaire.
Un demi-siècle plus tard,
on a un des astronautes d'Apollo
11 qui a planté ce drapeau.
Il est parmi nous ce soir.
(applaudissements)
Merci Buzz.
Cette année, les astronautes
américains vont retourner dans
l'espace sur des fusées
américaines.
(applaudissements)
Au XXe siècle, l'Amérique a
sauvé la liberté, à transformer
la science, a redéfini la classe
moyenne et quand on n'y pense,
il n'y a rien partout au monde
qui peut faire concurrence à
l'Amérique.
(applaudissements)
Aujourd'hui, il nous faut faire
preuve d'audace, ouvrir le
prochain chapitre de cette
grande aventure américaine.
Il nous faut en arriver
à un nouveau niveau de vie pour
le XXIe siècle est une qualité
de vie exceptionnelle pour tous
nos concitoyens. Ça, c'est à
notre portée, Mesdames et
Messieurs. Nous pouvons rendre
nos communautés plus sûres, nous
famille plus forte, notre
culture plus riche, notre foi
plus profonde et notre classe
moyenne plus importante et plus
prospère qu'à tout moment du
passé national.
(applaudissements)
Mais, il nous faut rejeter les
politiques de la vengeance, la
résistance, et de la rétribution
et accepter le potentiel sans
limite de la coopération, du
compromis et du bien commun.
(applaudissements)
Ensemble, nous pouvons mettre
fin à des décennies d'impasse
politique, nous pouvons jeter
des ponts, nous pouvons penser
d'anciennes plaies, nous pouvons
en arriver à de nouvelles
coalitions et forger de
nouvelles solutions, libérer la
promesse extraordinaire de
l'avenir américain.
La décision nous revient.
Il nous faut choisir entre la
grandeur, la part ils évacuent
les résultats ou la résistance,
la vision ou la vengeance,
le progrès incroyable où la
destruction sans fin.
Ce soir, je vous invite deviser
la grandeur.
(applaudissements)
Depuis deux ans, mon
gouvernement a agi de façon
urgent et à une vitesse
historique afin d'affronter les
problèmes qu'avait été négligé
par les deux parties pendant de
longues décennies. En deux ans,
depuis mon élection, nous avons
lancé un programme économique
sans précédent et c'est rare
qu'on a vu un tel essor
économique. On a rien vu de la
sorte. Nous avons créé 5,3
millions d'emplois nouveaux et
encore plus importants, nous
avons rajouté 600 000 nouveaux
emplois manufacturiers. En fait,
chacun disait que c'était une
tâche impossible. Mais le fait
demeure, nous ne faisons que
commencer.
(applaudissements)
Les salaires augmentent au
rythme le plus rapide depuis des
décennies.
Et elle augmente cette force
salariale pour les cols bleus et
cela à un rythme plus rapide que
l'on pensait possible. Tout près
de 5 millions d'Américains ne
prennent plus de coupons
alimentaires.
(applaudissements)
L'économie américaine croit
presque deux fois plus vite
aujourd'hui que quand j'ai pris
le pouvoir.
Et nous sommes vus comme étant
l'économie la plus forte du
monde entier est loin devant les
autres.
Le chômage a atteint le taux le
plus faible en 50 ans!
(applaudissements)
Les afro-américain, les hispano-
américain et les asiatiques
américains ont connu un taux de
chômage le plus faible de
l'histoire de notre pays, de
l'histoire de nos statistiques
même.
(applaudissements)
Le chômage pour les Américains
qui vivent avec un handicap a
également atteint un niveau
tellement bas que c'est du
jamais vu.
(applaudissements)
Il y a plus de gens qui
travaillent aujourd'hui qu'à
tout moment de l'histoire de
notre pays.
157 millions de personnes au
travail.
(applaudissements)
Nous avons fait adopter une
réduction d'impôt pour les
travailleurs et les familles.
Nous avons doublé le crédit
d'impôt pour les enfants.
(applaudissements)
Nous avons presque mis fin à la
taxe sur la succession ou la
taxe sur la mort comme on l'a
souvent appelé, sur les PME pour
les ranchs et aussi pour les
exploitations agricoles de
possession familiale.
(applaudissements)
Nous avons éliminé le mandat
individuelle très peu populaire
de la politique d'Obamacare.
(applaudissements)
Et pour les gens qui étaient
gravement malades, nous avons à
faire des remèdes et nous avons
fait adopter, et c'est très
important, le droit d'essayer,
le droit d'essayer des
médicaments, des remèdes, qui
n'avait pas nécessairement été
homologué.
(applaudissements)
Mon gouvernement a éliminé plus
de règlement en très peu de
temps et cela de loin en avance
surtout les autres
gouvernements, que ce soit
quatre ou huit ans cumulés.
(applaudissements)
Les entreprises reviennent au
pays.
Et cela, c'est en foule grâce à
notre réduction historique de
règlement et notre fardeau
fiscal.
(applaudissements)
Et nous avons libéré une
révolution dans le secteur
énergétique. Les États-Unis sont
maintenant le premier producteur
de pétrole et de gaz naturel au
monde.
(applaudissements)
Et maintenant, pour la toute
première fois depuis 65 ans,
nous sommes un pays exportateur
d'énergie.
(applaudissements)
Après 24 mois de rapide progrès,
notre économie fait l'envie du
monde entier. Et notre appareil
militaire et le plus puissant de
la planète et de loin.
Et l'Amérique...
(applaudissements)
Et l'Amérique de nouveau va de
victoire en victoire, de jour en
jour.
Chers congressistes,
l'état de notre union effort.
est fort.
(applaudissements)
C'est tellement agréable à
entendre.
Notre pays vit une effervescence
et notre économie connaît un
essor comme en tout cas, c'est
du jamais vu. Vendredi, on a
annoncé qu'il y avait eu 304 000
emplois de rajouter le mois
dernier seulement, presque le
double du chiffre auquel on
s'attendait.
(applaudissements)
Nous assistons à un miracle
économique aux États-Unis.
Et la seule chose qui puisse
l'arrêter, ce sont des guerres
un peu ridicules, la politique
ou des enquêtes partisanes
ridicules.
(applaudissements)
Si nous voulons connaître la
paix et une programme
législative riche, on ne peut
pas avoir de la guerre et des
enquêtes.
Cela ne fonctionne pas ainsi.
Il nous faut nous unir chez nous
pour que nous puissions vaincre
nos adversaires à l'étranger.
Cette nouvelle ère de
coopération peut commencer
avec la confirmation de plus de
300 nominés qui sont encore
paralysés par le Sénat.
Parfois, des années d'attente.
C'est inacceptable.
(applaudissements)
Le Sénat n'a pas agi sur sa
candidature et c'est injuste
envers les candidats est très
injuste envers le pays dans son
ensemble. Le temps est venu pour
l'action bipartite, croyez-le ou
non. Nous avons déjà prouvé que
cela est possible lors du
dernier congrès, les deux
parties se sont rassemblées afin
de faire adopter des lois sans
précédent pour régler la crise
des opiacés, également une
nouvelle loi sur l'agriculture,
des réformes à l'administration
des anciens combattants et après
quatre décennies, nous avons
fait adopter l'imputabilité
pour les anciens combattants
pour que nous puissions
congédier ceux qui sont
responsables de maltraitance à
l'égard de nos anciens
combattants.
(applaudissements)
Il y a à peine quelques semaines
d'ailleurs, les deux parties se
sont unies pour en arriver à une
réforme pénale sans précédent.
Ils ont dit que c'était
impossible, qu'on ne réussirait
pas. Eh bien, c'est faux, on a
réussi.
(applaudissements)
L'année dernière, par
l'entremise d'amis, j'ai entendu
parler d'Alice Johnson.
J'étais vraiment ému.
En 1997, Alice s'est retrouvée
en prison à perpétuité
comme résultat d'un délit non-
violent relié aux stupéfiants.
Pendant deux décennies, elle est
devenue un pasteur en prison à
inspirer d'autres à choisir une
meilleure voie.
Elle a eu un impact très
important sur la population
carcérale et au-delà des murs de
cette prison.
L'histoire d'Alice souligne
les injustices et les iniquités
qui peuvent exister dans la
détermination des peines et le
besoin de corriger cette
injustice criante.
Elle a passé tout près de 22 ans
derrière les barreaux.
Et elle s'attendait à mourir en
prison.
Au mois de juin,
par décret présidentiel,
j'ai mis un frein à sa peine.
Quand j'ai vu sa belle-famille
l'accueillir à la porte de la
prison, allant précis, à
pleurer, crier, à rire, à
l'étreindre, je voyais que
j'avais agi comme homme juste.
Alice est parmi nous ce soir
et c'est une femme incroyable et
formidable.
Alice!
(applaudissements)
on a donc changé les lois sur la
détermination des peines qui ont
lésé de façon disproportionnée
elle la communauté afro
américaine. Cette loi sur le
premier pas offre aux
délinquants non-violents de
retourner dans la société. Des
états un peu partout sont en
train d'emboîter le pas.
L'Amérique est une nation qui
croit en le pouvoir de la
rédemption. Nous avons aussi
parmi nous M. Charles du
Tennessee. 1996, quand il avait
30 ans, Matthew a reçu une peine
de 35 ans pour la vente de
stupéfiants et des délits
reliés. Sur les 20 ans qui ont
suivi, il a complété plus de 30,
Cours sur la Bible est devenu un
greffier juridique et a été un
montoir pour beaucoup de ses
amis en prison. Maintenant, il
est le premier à avoir été
libéré en vertu de cette
nouvelle loi qu'on qualifie de
loi sur les premiers pas.
Mathieu!
(applaudissements)
merci Matthew!
Bienvenue chez toi!
Et maintenant, républicains
comme démocrates doivent se
joindre afin d'affronter une
crise nationale de toute
urgence. Le congrès à 10 jours
pour adopter une loi qui pourra
financer notre gouvernement,
protégé Notre Patrie et
sécurisée notre frontière avec
le Mexique, cette frontière très
dangereuse. Le temps est venu
pour le congrès de montrer au
monde que l'Amérique s'est
engagée à mettre fin à
l'immigration illégale et de
mettre les passeurs, les cartes,
les narcotrafiquants et les
trafiquants d'êtres humains hors
du pays.
(applaudissements)
au moment de vous parler, de
grande caravane organisée marche
vers les États-Unis, vers nos
frontières. Nous venons
d'entendre que des villes
mexicaines, afin de déplacer ces
immigrants illégaux de leurs
villes et villages, ils sont en
train de rassembler des camions
et des autocars pour les amener
vers notre frontière, là où il y
a peu de protection à la
frontière. Moi, j'ai donné
l'ordre d'envoyer 3750 soldats à
la frontière afin de se préparer
pour cette déferlante. C'est une
question d'ordre moral. L'État
sans loi au sud de notre
frontière, c'est une menace pour
le bien-être financier, la
sécurité de chaque Américain.
Nous avons un devoir moral d'en
arriver à un système
d'immigration qui protège la vie
et les emplois de nos citoyens.
Cela inclut notre devoir envers
des millions d'immigrants qui
vivent ici parmi nous
aujourd'hui qui ont suivi les
règles, qui ont respecté nos
lois. Les immigrants légaux
enrichissent notre nation,
renforce notre société et cela
de façon multiple.
(applaudissements)
moi, je veux voir arriver des
gens chez nous, et cela, sans
limite sur le plan quantitatif.
Mais cela doit être fait selon
les règles, selon les lois. Ils
doivent arriver ici légalement.
Ce soir, je vous demande
de m'aider à défendre cette
frontière sud si dangereuse, mus
par l'amour envers votre pays.
Aucun enjeu n'illustre mieux la
scission entre la classe
politique de l'Amérique et la
classe ouvrière de l'Amérique
que l'immigration illégale. Les
politiciens et les donateurs
riches veulent des frontières
ouvertes pendant qu'ils vivent
dans le luxe, emmurés.
Entre-temps, les Américains de
la classe ouvrière doivent en
payer le lourd tribut de cette
migration illégale, des salaires
plus bas, des écoles et des
hôpitaux qui croulent. Les
hôpitaux sont tellement remplis
qu'on peut même pas rentrer. Une
criminalité à la hausse. Un
filet de sécurité sociale
trouée. La tolérance pour
l'immigration illégale, ce n'est
pas de la compassion, c'est de
la cruauté.
Une femme sur trois est agressée
sexuellement sur ce long périple
vers El Norte.
Les passeurs se servent des
enfants comme des pions afin
d'exploiter nos lois et d'en
arriver à notre territoire. Les
trafiquants humains et
trafiquants de sexe
profitent de ces aires ouvertes
pour vendre des milliers de
jeunes femmes en prostitution et
en esclavage moderne. Des
dizaines de milliers de nos
compatriotes sont tuées par des
stupéfiants mortels qui
traversent la frontière et
inonde nos villes. Cela inclut
le meth, l'héroïne et le
fentanyl. Et le gang sauvage
c'est enraciné dans une
vingtaine d'états américains.
Pas plus tard qu'hier, membre du
MS 13 a été pris en détention
pour une fusillade sur une
plate-forme de métro dans la
ville de New York. Nous sommes
en train de retirer ses membres
de gangs par milliers. Ils vont
continuer à revenir, à franchir
tiers. Année après année,
combien d'Américains sont
assassinés par des étrangers
sans-papiers? J'ai appris à
connaître beaucoup de mère et de
pères, de familles généreuses
qui ont perdu un être cher. Mais
personne ne doit souffrir cette
douleur horrible qui est la
leur. Ce soir, parmi nous, il y
a Debrah. Les parents de Debrah
ont été assassiné il y a trois
semaines dans leur maison par un
sans-papier. Ils avaient franchi
le cap des 80. Ils ont quatre
enfants, 11 petits-enfants et 20
petits petits-enfants. Parmi
nous ce soir, la petite-fille de
ces gens et l'arrière-petite-
fille. Levez-vous s'il vous
plaît. Peu de gens peuvent
comprendre votre douleur merci
de votre présence.
(applaudissements)
moi, je ne pourrais oublier
je vais me battre pour préserver
la mémoire de Gérald et de
Sharon pour que cela ne se
reproduit jamais. Pas une seule
vie américaine de plus devrait
être perdu parce que notre
nation n'a pas réussi à protéger
sa frontière. Depuis deux ans,
nos douaniers ont procédé à 266
000 arrestations de ses sans-
papiers criminelles et cela
inclut ceux qui ont été accusés
ou reconnus coupables de tout
près de 100 000 agressions, 4000
crimes sexuels et 4000 meurtres.
Nous avons parmi nous ce soir un
de ses héros, l'agent spécial
des douanes M. Hernández.
(applaudissements)
merci.
Quand il était tout jeune,
monsieur Fernandez est arrivé
avec sa famille en toute
légalité en partance de la
République Dominicaine. À l'âge
de huit ans, il a dit à son papa
qui voulait devenir un agent
spécial. Aujourd'hui, il dirige
des enquêtes sur ce fléau du
trafic sexuel international.
Elvin a dit : si je peux
m'assurer que ces jeunes filles
puissent obtenir justice,
j'aurais réussi dans mon
travail. Grâce au travail
d'Elvin et de tous ses
collègues, au-delà de 300 femmes
essayons pu être rescapées de
l'horreur de ce fléau horrible.
Et plus de 1500 trafiquants
sadiques ont été envoyés en
prison.
(applaudissements)
nous allons toujours soutenir
les hommes et les femmes
courageux des forces de l'ordre.
Et je vous promets ici ce soir
que je n'avais jamais abolir nos
héros des forces de l'ordre et
des troupes frontalières et
douanières.
(applaudissements)
mon gouvernement a envoyé au
congrès une proposition visant à
mettre fin à la crise sur la
frontière méridionale. Il est
question d'aide humanitaire,
plus de force de l'ordre,
détection des stupéfiants au
port, l'élimination des
échappatoires qui permettent le
trafic d'enfants et le plan pour
une nouvelle barrière physique
ou un mur afin de protéger
toutes ces zones entre les
portes d'entrée. Par le passé,
la plupart des gens dans cette
salle ont voté pour un mur. Mais
le mur n'a jamais été construit.
Moi, je vais réussir à le faire
construire.
(applaudissements)
c'est une barrière d'acier qui
est intelligente, stratégique,
convoi en travers et pas
seulement un mur en béton. Cette
barrière sera déployée dans les
zones identifiées par les
douaniers commettant les zones
les plus à risque. Et c'est
agents vous diront que là où les
barrières s'érigent, les
traverses ou les gens qui
traversent de façon illégale,
ces chiffres chutent, sont en
chute libre.
À une certaine époque, Santiago
avait le plus grand nombre de
traversées illégales au pays. En
réaction, une barrière très
solide a été érigée. Cette
barrière puissante a presque mis
fin complètement aux traversées
illégales. La ville frontalière
d'El Paso au Texas avait des
taux de criminalité violente
très élevée, l'un des taux les
plus élevés au pays. Ils étaient
une ville qui était parmi les
plus dangereuses dans notre
pays. Aujourd'hui, après la
construction de la barrière, une
barrière vraiment solide, El
Paso est devenu une de nos vies
les plus sécuritaires.
Bref, les murs fonctionnent. Et
les murs sauvent des vies.
(applaudissements)
alors, travaillons ensemble,
trouvons un compromis, arrivons
à nous entendre pour que nous
puissions assurer la sécurité de
l'Amérique. À mesure que nous
travaillons pour défendre la
sécurité de nos concitoyens, il
nous faut également nous assurer
le renouveau économique et que
sa cadence puisse accélérer. Il
n'y a personne qui a profité
davantage notre économie
effervescente que les femmes qui
ont comblée 58 % des emplois
créés l'année dernière.
(applaudissements)
vous ne deviez pas faire cela.
Mais merci. Merci beaucoup.
Tous les Américains, toutes les
américaines peuvent être fières
que nous avons plus de femmes
dans la main-d'oeuvre qu'à tout
moment de notre histoire.
(applaudissements)
attendez, vous assoyez pas,
Madame. Vous allez aimer ce qui
arrive. I siècle après que le
congrès adopte des l'amendements
constitutionnels donnant aux
femmes le droit de voter, nous
avons également plus de femmes
qui siègent au congrès qu'à tout
moment de notre histoire.
(applaudissements)
c'est bien. C'est formidable.
C'est vraiment bien.
Félicitations. Dans le cadre de
notre engagement à améliorer les
perspectives d'avenir pour les
femmes partout, ce jeudi, nous
allons lancer la première
initiative gouvernementale se
polarisation sur la situation
économique des femmes dans les
pays en voie de développement.
Afin de nous inspirer, une des
priorités semble fondamentale :
inverser des décennies de
politique commerciale
catastrophique.
La Chine après avoir volé notre
propriété intellectuelle, le vol
d'emploi américain et la
richesse américaine, c'est fini,
cette époque.
C'est pourquoi tout récemment
nous avons imposé des tarifs sur
250 milliards de dollars de
biens chinois. Maintenant, notre
trésor reçoit des milliards de
dollars. Mais je ne veux pas
blâmer la Chine d'avoir profité
de nous. Je jette le blâme sur
nos représentants qui ont permis
cette trahison. J'ai beaucoup de
respect pour le président
chinois. Nous travaillons
maintenant sur une nouvelle
entente commerciale avec la
Chine. Cette entente doit
inclure des changements
structurels réels pour mettre
fin aux pratiques commerciales
déloyales, réduire notre déficit
commerciale chronique et
protéger l'emploi américain.
Une autre grave erreur
historique, c'était la
catastrophe connue l'acronyme à
l'ENA. J'ai rencontré des gens
de bien d'autres états dont les
rêves ont volé en éclats. Après
la signature de la l'aréna.
Pendant des années les
politiciens ont promis qu'ils
allaient renégocier, avoir de
meilleures conditions. Personne
n'avait essayé jusqu'à
maintenant. Notre nouveaux
accords Canada États-Unis
Mexique va remplacer la l'aLENA
et va offrir au travailleur
américain des perspectives
jusqu'alors rêvées. J'espère que
vous allez adopter cet accord
pour que nous y puissions
ramener nos emplois
manufacturiers, élargir
l'agriculture américaine,
protéger notre propriété
intellectuelle et nous assurer
qu'un plus grand nombre d'autos
sont assemblés jusqu'à la toute
fin et intempéries de ces
merveilleux mots fabriqués aux
États-Unis.
Ce soir, je vous demande
également d'adopter la loi sur
la réciprocité commerciale pour
que si jamais un pays nous
impose un tarif inéquitable sur
un de nos produits, nous pouvons
imposer le même tarif sur le
même produit qu'ils essaient de
nous vendre.
Les deux parties devraient être
en mesure de s'unir à fin de ce
grand projet visant à
reconstruire notre
infrastructure qui est en ruine.
Je sais que le congrès a hâte
d'adopter un projet de loi sur
l'infrastructure. J'ai hâte de
travailler avec vous sur un
projet de loi visant à
reconstruire et réinvestir dans
l'infrastructure et cela inclut
dans les industries de pointe.
Ce n'est pas une option,
Mesdames et Messieurs. C'est une
nécessité.
Et la prochaine grande priorité
pour moi et pour nous tous et
toutes, ça devrait être
d'abaisser le coût des soins de
santé et des médicaments
prescrits. Et de protéger les
patients avec des conditions
préexistantes.
Déjà, grâce à mes efforts, en
2018, les prix des médicaments
ont connu leur baisse la plus
importante en 46 ans.
(applaudissements)
mais il nous faut faire
davantage. Il est inacceptable
que des Américains paient
tellement plus que les gens dans
d'autres pays. Pour les mêmes
médicaments. Parfois, voire
souvent, fabriqué à la même
usine c'est une erreur. C'est
inacceptable. C'est inéquitable.
Ensemble, il faut le stopper
net.
Je demande au congrès d'adopter
un projet de loi qui pourra
finalement s'attaquer aux
problèmes de cette transparence
des prix et de l'équité pour les
patients américains.
Il nous faut également exiger
des grandes pharmaceutiques, des
compagnies d'assurances, des
hôpitaux de dévoiler les vrais
prix afin que nous puissions en
arriver à une plus grande
concurrence et faire abaisser
les prix de beaucoup.
(applaudissements)
aucune influence dans l'histoire
a fait davantage pour faire
avancer la condition humaine que
la liberté américaine.
Depuis quelques années, nous
avons connu des progrès
remarquables dans le combat
contre le VIH sida. Des percées
scientifiques ont fait
apparaître des solutions à
portée de main. Mon budget a
demandé au républicains et aux
démocrates de s'engager afin
d'éliminer l'épidémie de VIH
disons sur notre territoire
national. Nous avons tant
progressé.
Ensemble, nous allons vaincre le
sida en Amérique et au-delà.
Ce soir, j'aimerais également
vous inviter à vous joindre à
moi dans un autre combat.
Un combat national, le combat
contre le cancer chez les
enfants.
(applaudissements)
aux côtés de Mélania,
on retrouve une petite fille
courageuse de 10 ans. À chaque
anniversaire...
(applaudissements)
Allô Grace!
Chaque anniversaire depuis
qu'elle a eu quatre ans, Grâce a
demandé à ses amis de faire des
dons à l'hôpital Saint Jude.
Elle ne savait pas qu'un jour
elle hisserait patients. Et
c'est ce qui est arrivé. L'année
dernière, Grace a reçu un
diagnostic de cancer du cerveau.
Elle a commencé des traitements
aux rayons X. En même temps,
elle a pu rallier sa communauté.
Elle a pu recueillir plus de 40
000 $ pour ce combat contre le
cancer.
(applaudissements)
quand Grace à compléter ces
traitements à l'automne dernier,
les médecins et les infirmières
l'ont applaudi. Je l'adore!
Elle a accroché une affiche qui
disait : dernière journée de
chimio!
(applaudissements)
Merci Grace!
Tu es une source incroyable
d'inspiration pour chacun dans
cette salle. Merci.
Beaucoup de cancers pédiatriques
qui n'ont pas vu de nouvelles
thérapies apparaître en des
décennies ont reçu une
allocation de 500 millions de
dollars sur 10 ans pour financer
cette recherche critique afin
d'aider les parents qui
travaillent le temps nous
d'adopter le choix scolaire pour
les enfants américains.
(applaudissements)
Je suis également fié d'être le
premier président à inclure dans
mon budget un plan pour origine
de congés parentaux énumérait
pour que chaque nouveau parent
ait l'occasion de s'attacher à
leur nouveau-né.
(applaudissements)
Difficile de s'imaginer un plus
grand contraste que cette image
magnifique d'une mère tenant son
nouveau-né que ce qu'on a vu
depuis quelques jours.
Les législateurs à New York qui
(...)
Ce sont des bébés merveilleux
qui n'auront jamais la chance de
partager l'amour et leur rêve
avec le monde.
Ensuite, nous avons eu ce cas de
gouverneur de la Virginie qui a
dit qu'il exécuterait un bébé
après sa naissance afin de
défendre la dignité de chaque
personne, je demande au congrès
d'adopter un projet de loi
afin d'interdire l'avortement
en troisième trimestre des
enfants, qui peuvent ressentir
la douleur dans le ventre de
leur mère.
(applaudissements)
Travaillons ensemble à fin
d'honorer une culture qui chérit
une vie innocente.
(applaudissements)
Et réaffirmons une vérité
fondamentale : tous les enfants
nés ou à naître son façonné de
l'image sacrée de Dieu.
Un de mes priorités, c'est de
protéger la sécurité nationale
de l'Amérique.
Depuis deux ans, nous avons
commencé à rebâtir l'appareil
militaire de l'Amérique avec 700
milliards de dollars l'année
dernière et 716 milliards de
dollars cette année-ci.
Nous exigeons également des
autres pays qui paient leur
juste part.
Enfin, enfin!
(applaudissements)
Pendant de longues années, les
États-Unis se faisaient
maltraiter par l'OTAN.
C'était nous ami en fait, nos
alliés. Mais maintenant, nous
avons réussi à obtenir depuis
quelques années une augmentation
200 milliards de dollars
dans les dépenses de défense
dans nos pays alliés.
Ils clamaient l'impossibilité de
la tâche. Et bien non, c'est
fait.
(applaudissements)
Dans le cadre de notre
reconstruction militaire, nous
développons un système
antimissile à la fine pointe de
la science. Grâce à notre
gouvernement, nous allons jamais
nous excuser de faire avancer
l'état de l'Amérique. Par
exemple, il y a des décennies
aux États-Unis, on a conclut un
traité avec la Russie selon
lequel nous étions prêts, à
réduire nos capacités de
missiles. Pendant que nous avons
adhéré à la lettre, la Russie a
violé les termes et les
conditions du traité de façon
répétée. Ça fait des années que
ça dure. C'est pourquoi j'ai
annoncé que les États-Unis
allaient se retirer de façon
officielle du traité INF sur les
forces nucléaires de portée
intermédiaire.
(applaudissements)
Nous n'avons vraiment pas le
choix.
Est-il possible de négocier un
autre accord en ajoutant la
Chine et d'autres?
Peut-être que ce ne sera pas
possible.
Dans un tel cas, nous allons
dépenser davantage que tous les
autres et cela de loin.
(applaudissements)
Dans le cadre de cette nouvelle
diplomatie, nous continuons
notre poussée historique pour la
paix sur la péninsule coréenne.
Nos otages sont revenus chez
nous. Les essais nucléaires sont
choses du passé et il n'y a pas
eu de missiles lancés en plus de
15 mois.
Si je n'avais pas été élu
président des États-Unis
d'Amérique, aujourd'hui, en ce
moment, selon moi, nous serions
dans une guerre importante avec
la Corée du Nord.
(applaudissements)
Il reste beaucoup de travail à
abattre, mais nos relations avec
Kim Jong-Un et une bonne
relation. Nous allons nous
rencontrer à nouveau les 27 et
28 févriers au Vietnam.
(applaudissements)
Il y a deux semaines, les États-
Unis ont reconnu de façon
officielle le gouvernement
légitime du Venezuela et son
nouveau président par intérim
Juan Guaido.
(applaudissements)
Nous nous tenons debout
aux côtés du peuple vénézuélien
dans leur quête de liberté et
nous dénonçons la brutalité du
régime Maduro.
Donc les politiques socialistes
ont transformé cette nation
d'une des plus riches de
l'Amérique du Sud à un état
de pauvreté abjecte et de
désespoir.
(applaudissements)
Chez nous, ici, aux États-Unis,
nous sommes à l'armée par ces
appels que l'on attend visant à
adopter le socialisme dans notre
pays.
(huées)
L'Amérique a été fondée sur la
liberté et l'indépendance et non
la coercition des gouvernements
et la prise de contrôle.
Nous sommes libres et nous
allons demeurer libre.
(applaudissements)
Ce soir, nous nous renouvelons
cette détermination que
l'Amérique ne deviendra jamais
un pays socialiste.
(applaudissements)
Un des séries de défis les plus
complexes que l'on doit relever,
c'est au Moyen-Orient.
Notre approche se fonde sur des
principes, sur le réalisme fondé
sur des principes et non des
théories discréditées qui n'ont
rien donné pendant des
décennies. C'est pour cela que
le gouvernement a reconnu la
capitale réelle d'Israël et que
nous avons fermement ouvert
l'ambassade américaine à
Jérusalem.
(applaudissements)
Nos soldats courageux se battent
au Moyen-Orient depuis tout près
de 19 ans.
En Afghanistan, Irak, tout près
de 7000 héros américains ont
sacrifié leur vie,.
Plus de 52 000 Américains ont
été gravement blessés.
Et nous avons dépensé plus de 7
millions de dollars au Moyen-
Orient, à faire la guerre.
À titre de candidat aux
présidentielles, j'ai promis une
nouvelle approche. Les grandes
nations ne s'embourbent pas dans
les guerres sans fin.
(applaudissements)
Quand j'ai pris le pouvoir,
Daesh contrôler l'Irak et la
Syrie. Cela ne fait que deux ans
de cela. Aujourd'hui, nous avons
libéré presque tout le
territoire de l'emprise de ces
sanguinaires, de ces monstres.
Aujourd'hui, en travaillant avec
nos alliés visant à détruire les
vestiges de Daesh, étant que
nous puissions offrir à nos
soldats une acclamation de
bienvenue chez nous. J'ai
également accéléré les
négociations visant en arriver à
un règlement politique en
Afghanistan.
Le côté adverse est également
très content de se retrouver
à la table des négociations.
Nos troupes ont fait preuve de
vaillant sans limite et grâce
alors courage, nous sommes
maintenant en train de
poursuivre une solution
politique à ce conflit prolongé.
(applaudissements)
En Afghanistan, mon gouvernement
est en pourparlers constructives
avec un certain nombre de
groupes afghans et cela
inclus les talibans.
À mesure que nous progressons
dans ces négociations, nous
serons en mesure de réduire la
présence de nos troupes et de
polariser notre attention sur
la lutte contre le terrorisme.
C'est ce que nous avons
l'intention de faire.
Nous ne savons pas encore si
nous parviendrons à nous
entendre, mais nous savons
qu'après deux décennies de
guerre, l'heure est venue
d'essayer au moins d'en arriver
à la paix.
L'autre côté, le côté adverse,
désire la même chose. Le temps
est arrivé.
(applaudissements)
Par-dessus tout, les amis comme
les ennemis ne doivent jamais
douter de la puissance de notre
nation, de notre volonté à
défendre notre peuple.
Il y a 18 ans, des terroristes
violents se sont attaqués au USS
Cold et le mois dernier, les
forces américaines ont tué un
des chefs de cet attentat.
(applaudissements)
Nous avons le grand honneur
d'être en présence de l'homme
dont le fils, un marine, était
un des 17 marins qu'on a perdus
tragiquement à bord de ce
navire. Tom, nous vous
promettons de nous rappeler
toujours de nous rappeler les
héros de ce navire.
Merci.
(applaudissements)
Mon gouvernement a agi de façon
décisive pour affronter le para
étatique qui est de premier plan
de Théodore. Il est question du
régime de T Horan. C'est un
régime radical. Ce sont vraiment
de mauvais acteurs.
Et pour s'assurer que cette
dictature corrompue ne puisse
jamais mettre le grappin sur des
armes nucléaires, j'ai retiré
les États-Unis de cet accord sur
le nucléaire iranien, cet accord
désastreux.
(applaudissements)
L'automne dernier, nous avons
mis en place les sanctions les
plus sévères jamais imposés sur
un pays dans l'histoire de
l'Amérique.
Nous n'allons pas détourner
notre regard de régime qui
chante mort à l'Amérique et qui
menace le peuple juif de
génocide.
(applaudissements)
Il ne faut jamais ignorer ce vil
poison qu'est l'antisémitisme ou
ceux qui propagent ses méfaits.
Avec une seule fois, il nous
faut affronter cette haine
partout et à chaque fois qu'elle
surgit.
Il y a quelques mois, 11
Américains de foi juive étaient
assassinés dans une attaque
antisémite dans une synagogue
Pittsburg. L'officier est arrivé
en courant. Il a été arrêté par
sept coups de feu en poursuivant
le tueur. Il vient de sortir de
sa 12e opération chirurgicale.
Il en aura bien d'autres. Mais
il s'est déplacé pour être parmi
nous ce soir.
Agent Mattsson, s'il vous plaît.
(applaudissements)
Merci.
Nous sommes reconnaissants pour
l'éternité.
Ce soir, nous avons également
parmi nous un survivant de
Pittsburg.
Il est arrivé à la synagogue au
moment du début de la fusillade.
Mais non seulement a-t-il pu
s'échapper à la mort l'automne
dernier, il y a plus de 70 ans,
il a survécu de justesse au camp
de concentration de nazis.
Aujourd'hui, il termine sa 81e
année.
C'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui.
(applaudissements)
(rires)
(Happy birthday)
(applaudissements)
- Merci!
(rires)
- Il ne le ferait pas pour moi,
tu sais.
Il nous dit qu'il se rappelle
encore le moment précis, il y a
tout prêt de 75 ans, après 10
mois dans un camp de
concentration, quand lui et sa
famille ont été placée dans un
train et on leur a dit qu'il se
rendait à l'autre camp. Tout à
coup, le train s'est arrêté.
Et c'était vraiment violent
comme choc. Un soldat est
apparu.
La famille se préparait au pire.
Et ensuite, son père a crié de
joie. Ce sont les Américains! Ce
sont les Américains!
(applaudissements)
Merci.
Un autre survivant est parmi
nous ce soir.
Il était prisonnier dans un camp
de concentration. Il se rappelle
avoir regardé dans un petit trou
à travers un mur, en fait la
voie d'une paroi d'un wagon,
quand les soldats américains
sont arrivés. C'était la preuve
que Dieu existait et ils sont
arrivés du ciel. Ils sont venus
du ciel.
J'ai commencé ce soir en
honorant trois soldats qui se
sont battus le 6 juin 1944 lors
de la seconde guerre mondiale.
Un d'entre eux était (..) mais
l'histoire d'Herman est plus
long. Un an après son arrivée en
Normandie, il était un de soldat
américain qui a aidé à libérer
le camp de Dakow.
(applaudissements)
Il était un des Américains qui
sont venus à la rescousse de jeu
Joshua dansait enfin sur terre.
Près de 75 ans plus tard, ils
sont ensemble dans la galerie
publique, ce soir, assis à côté
de l'autre, ici, dans le foyer
de la liberté américaine.
Votre présence ici est un
honneur pour nous.
Merci beaucoup de votre
présence.
(applaudissements)
Merci.
Quand les soldats américains
sont partis sous ces cieux
sombres pour traverser la
Manche, à l'aube du 6 juin 1944,
ils étaient tous jeunes. Ils
avaient 18 ou 19 ans dans leurs
embarcations fragiles en
direction de cette bataille
historique, un des batailles
les plus célèbres dans
l'histoire de la guerre.
Ils ne savaient pas s'il allait
survivre une heure. Ils ne
savaient pas s'ils allaient
vieillir. Mais il savait que
l'Amérique devait absolument
l'emporter.
Leur cause, c'était notre
nation. Et de génération encore
à naître.
Pourquoi l'ont-ils fait?
Ils l'ont fait pour l'Amérique.
Ils l'ont fait pour nous.
Tout ce qui a suivi depuis
notre trillion contre le
communisme, nos grandes
enjambées dans les découvertes
diverses, notre progrès sans
égal vers l'égalité et la
justice, tout cela est possible
grâce au sang, grâce au courage,
grâce aux larmes et aux visions
de ces Américains qui nous
précèdent.
Pensez à ce Capitole.
Pensez à cette assemblée.
Où les députés et les sénateurs
avant vous ont voté pour mettre
fin à l'esclavage, construire
les autoroutes, les chemins de
fer et de vaincre du fascisme.
D'en arriver aux droits civiques
et de mettre fin aux empires
maléfiques.
Ici, ce soir, nous avons des
législateurs de partout dans
cette république magnifique que
la nôtre.
Vous êtes arrivé des rivages
rocheux du Maine, des pics
volcaniques d'Hawaï et des
déserts rouges d'Arizona, des
forêts vertes du Kentucky et des
plages dorées de la Californie.
Ensemble, nous représentons la
nation la plus extra ordinaire
de toute l'histoire. Qu'allons-
nous faire de ce moment?
Comment vont-ils se rappeler de
nous?
Je demande aux hommes et aux
femmes de ce congrès : regardez
ces possibilités qui se
présentent à nous.
Nos réalisations les plus
enivrantes nous attendent.
Nos destinées les plus
ravissantes nous attendent.
Nos plus grandes victoires nous
attendent.
Nous n'avons même pas encore
commencé à rêver.
Il nous faut choisir si nous
voulons être définis par nos
différences ou si nous avons
l'audace de les transcender.
Il nous faut choisir si nous
allons gaspiller notre héritage
magnifique ou si nous allons
déclarer fièrement que nous
sommes américains.
Nous réussissons ce qui est
incroyable. Nous allons au défi
de l'impossible. Nous avons en
nous la conquête de l'inconnu.
C'est le moment. Le moment est
venu de revitaliser l'imaginaire
américain. Le moment est venu
de cette audace nécessaire pour
le sommet le plus élevé et
chercher l'étoile la plus
brillante. Le temps est venu de
renouveler les liens de l'amour,
de la loyauté et du souvenir qui
nous unisse comme citoyen, comme
voisins, comme patriotes.
C'est notre avenir, c'est notre
destin. Et c'est notre choix
personnel et collectif. Je vous
demande de choisir la grandeur.
Quelles que soient les épreuves
devant nous, quel que soit les
défis à relever, il nous faut
avancer ensemble.
Il nous faut garder l'Amérique
dans le coeur avant tout. Il nos
faut garder la flamme de la
liberté dans nos armes et il
nous faut toujours tenir la foi
dans le destin de l'Amérique.
Qu'une nation sous Dieu
doit être la promesse et
l'espoir et la lumière et la
gloire parmi toutes les nations
du monde. Merci, que Dieu vous
bénisse.
Et que Dieu bénisse l'Amérique.
(applaudissements)
C'était le deuxième discours sur
l'état de l'union du président
Donald 30. Un discours assez
sobre, qui faisait un grand
appel à l'unité, à la grandeur
de l'Amérique. C'était un peu
son thème conducteur de ses
discours misant sur une économie
forte et sur la nécessaire
protection des Américains à
travers son discours encore une
fois, sur l'immigration légale
et le mur. Des bons moments, des
moments moins bons, mais un
discours parsemé d'exemples à
caractère très Humain. On pense
à la réforme de la justice
criminelle. J'aimerais savoir de
vous, d'abord Karine, qu'est-ce
que vous redonnez
essentiellement de ce discours?
- En fait, j'ai trouvé qu'il
avait réussi à contrôler
l'essentiel de ses titres.
Je trouve qu'il a vraiment mit
les démocrates sur la défensive
avec ses discours en disant : je
vous tends la main, je trouve
des points de convergence dans
nos politiques, notamment sur la
santé. Il a donné plusieurs
exemples...
- On le voit serrer la main du
juge Cavanna, justement. Il aura
été question d'avortement.
- Il y a donc quelques points de
convergence et il a appelé à
l'unité. Autrement dit, si les
démocrates arrivent pas à
s'entendre avec lui, ce sera de
leur faute.
- Leur est au compromis. Que
retenez-vous, John?
- Je suis d'accord qu'il a
réussi sur le ton, dans son
ensemble. C'est clair qu'il est
très partisan sur le mur, très
partisan sur les questions de
l'enquête. On aura des points
forts tantôt. Mais je pense que
c'est traditionnel aux États-
Unis que les discours de
l'union, habituellement, c'est
gagné des points dans les
sondages au président. Je pense
que M. Trump n'a pas perdu :. Il
avait vraiment besoin de ça. On
a senti que les républicains
dans la salle voulaient
l'encourager car ils ont eu
quatre à cinq mois de mauvaises
nouvelles : perte de la chambre
et le shutdown. Déclare que les
sondages disaient que Madame
Pelosi a gagné haut la main.
Dans un sens, il s'est réchappé
un peu, mais on voit quand même
que M. Trump va être assez
combatif dans l'après discours.
- Il le veut, sont mûres. C'est
clair.
- Il le veut, mais encore, peut-
être que les démocrates
pourraient changer, mais le
problème que j'ai senti, c'est
que les démocrates n'ont pas
réussi à imposer, même leur
victoire de l'automne passé, à
imposer une vision d'où il
voulait année pays. La dernière
fois qu'un président a fait un
discours de la nation à 42 ou 40
% dans les sondages, c'était
Ronald Reagan et à sa deuxième
année, comme président, il a
gagné deux ans plus tard dans 49
états. Donc l'économie, état de
l'économie, même s'il y a déjà
des faits qui montent qu'il a
exagéré déchets, on peut pas
nier que cette économie
fonctionne. Et autre chose à
tenir compte, c'est
l'infrastructure et la Chine.
- Nous allons en parler après la
pause. Après la pause, nous
allons aussi parler avec
Christian Latreille et
réentendre des moments forts,
des moments émouvants. Madame
Monsieur, restez avec nous, on
va rester après la pause.
Le discours de l'état de l'union
de Donald Trump, étaient-ils
très présidentiels? Est-ce que
30 gagnent des points ce soir?
Est-ce qu'il lance, au fond, sa
campagne présidentielle pour
2020. Christian, vous, à
Washington, qu'est-ce que vous
avez retenu de ce discours? Vous
a-t-il étonné? Soit par le ton
ou par les priorités établies.
- Bien écouté, il y a toujours
de Donald Trump. Celui devant
ses partisans, celui en
conférence de presse qui a de la
difficulté à se contrôler, qui
est très émotif, qui lance des
flèches à tout le monde, cette à
tout le monde, et de Donald
Trump qu'on a vu ce soir.
Lorsqu'il un texte à lire,
lorsque la télé souffert devant
lui, il est, en général, assez
bon. Ce soir, c'est ce qu'on a
senti. Il était en maîtrise, il
était un américain parmi tant
d'autres. Il a vraiment tendu la
main. Il a tenté de penser
les plaies, que les vieilles
querelles se terminent. C'est le
message, du moins, qu'il a lancé
et c'est le même message qu'il
avait lancé l'année dernière,
mais c'est un peu le problème
avec M. Trump. Ça ne dure jamais
très longtemps. On ne sait pas
dans quelques heures, quelques
jours qu'elle tweete va venir.
Et probablement qu'au fond de
lui-même, il aimerait bien faire
en sorte de pouvoir travailler
avec les démocrates
éventuellement pour faire
avancer les États-Unis, mais
sera-t-il l'homme de la
situation? Sera-t-il le
président capable de faire en
sorte qu'il puisse travailler
avec Madame Pelosi et son équipe
au Congrès? Il n'a plus vraiment
le choix en ce moment s'il veut
voter un programme
d'infrastructures, baisser le
prix des médicaments, etc. Il va
devoir, effectivement, continuer
cette politique de la main
tendue. Jusqu'à quand ça va
durer? C'est tout le problème.
- Avec la victoire du mois de
février, on va voir s'il...
il a parlé beaucoup de son mur
mais en même temps, il y avait
une sorte de mise en garde :
arrêter ces enquêtes ridicules
partisanes à la chambre des
représentants car on sait que la
chambre lance déjà des enquêtes
et va faire des subpoena.
- Oui, et ça, les démocrates
n'ont pas l'intention de lâcher
le morceau à ce niveau. Ils
veulent enquêter sur tous, tout
ce qui concerne M. Trump.
Évidemment, lorsque M. Trump
parlait d'une enquête ridicule,
il parlait surtout de l'enquête
Mueller. M. Mueller qui n'a
toujours pas rendu public son
rapport, rapporte se fait
attendre, qui devrait en en
principe, être rédigé ou terminé
d'être rédigé au cours des
prochaines semaines ou des
prochains mois, et qui pourrait
faire très mal être. Tournant de
la présidence 30. Alors M. Trump
n'a pas manqué l'occasion ce
soir de dire des millions
d'Américains que si l'Amérique
continue sur cette lancée, c'est
l'Amérique veut continuer
d'avoir une économie en
croissance et être prospère, il
faut oser l'écrire il est
enquête. Ces enquêtes, en ce
moment, vise ils font très mal
politiquement et pourraient lui
faire très mal également pour sa
réélection en 2020.
- Encore aujourd'hui, on
apprenait qu'il y aurait enquête
très approfondie sur le comité
de son investiture. L'argent
dépensé, plusieurs personnes
vont être contraintes de
répondre à plusieurs questions,
alors je vous laisse filer au
Téléjournal avec Céline. Il y a
le discours ce soir, mais dans
les heures qui viennent demain
matin, ce sont les fameux
tweets, hein? Et le ton qu'il va
emprunter dès demain pour suivre
ses intentions. Merci, bonne
soirée.
Alors John et Karine, on peut
peut-être écouter quelques
extraits car la question du mur,
n'est-ce pas, est très, très
importante toujours.
- Surtout à court terme.
- On va écouter un extrait de
son discours.
(anglais)
- This is a smart...
- C'est une barrière d'acier qui
est intelligente, stratégique.
On peut voir à travers est non
seulement un mur de béton, cette
barrière sera déployée dans les
zones identifiées par les
douaniers, comme étant les zones
les plus à risque. Et ces agents
vous diront que là où les
barrières s'élèvent et
s'érigent, les... traverses, ou
les gens qui traversent de façon
illégale, eh bien, ces chiffres
achètent, sont en chute libre.
- Alors il a voulu dire, dans le
fond, que le mur met à l'abri
les Américains et que c'était
d'une absolue nécessité.
- Et les chiffres, et les
enquêtes, et toutes les données
vont en sens contraire. Les murs
ne fonctionnent pas parce qu'il
y a tout plein de façon de les
contourner. Et ça augmente la
criminalité. En fait, ça crée
tous les problèmes que ça soit
évité. Il le sait, les
Américains le savent et ce qui
est intéressant, et on a vu
Nancy Pelosi sourire derrière
lui, il a donné plusieurs
définitions disant : faites
comme vous voulez, en béton,
qu'on va travers, en notant
quelque chose que je puisse
créer un mur.
- En plus de cet extrait, il y
avait toute la déclinaison des
dangers que courent les
Américains, les crimes commis.
Il ne passe pas le test, M.
Trump.
- Il exagère, évidemment, il
déforme les données. Nous sommes
dans une situation où il a voulu
faire une dernière plaidoirie.
Il n'y a pas parlé d'urgence
nationale. Il sait que ses
représentations républicaines à
la chambre au Sénat ne sont pas
en faveur d'une urgence
nationale. Il crée un précédent
pour quelque chose qui n'est pas
vraiment une vraie crise, quand
un président démocrate va être
pouvoir, il pourra utiliser ses
précédents pour le changement
climatique ou le contrôle des
armes. Donc, les républicains
ont perdu précédent et je pense
que 30, sur ce point, abaisser
le ton.
- Mais il n'y a aucune piste sur
ce qui va faire en février. La
marge de négociation.
- S'il prévoit qu'il y a un
autre shutdown, il est clair que
les gains qu'il va faire ce
soir, il va les perdre.
- Alors on peut peut-être
écouter un autre extrême. Celui-
ci, est-ce que c'est sûr et...
écoutons la place des femmes car
c'est un point de consensus.
On n'a jamais vu autant de
femmes au Congrès américain et
c'est un moment d'unité.
- Tous les Américains, toutes
lès américaines peuvent être
fières que nous avons plus de
femmes dans la main-d'oeuvre quà
tout moment dans notre histoire.
(applaudissements)
Attendez, ne vous assoyez pas,
Mesdames. Vous allez bien aimer
ce qui arrive. Exactement I
siècle après que le congrès ait
adopté l'amendement
constitutionnel, donnant aux
femmes le droit de voter,
nous avons également plus de
femmes qui siègent au congrès à
tout moment de notre histoire!
(applaudissements)
- USA!
USA!
- Alors, plus de femmes dans
l'histoire, des femmes vêtues de
blanc car c'est le centième
anniversaire du droit de vote.
C'est une manière intéressant
de bonne guerre car il a perdu,
à cause de ses 40 personnes qui
ont été élues à la chambre des
représentants, en plus.
- Il reconnaît que ces femmes
arrivent massivement et il leur
a tendu la main de différentes
façons. Il a proposé des mesures
notamment sur la sécurité des
femmes. Il a également parlé de
congé parental.
- Il en annonce. On existe pas,
à moins d'avoir une assurance
privée, je ne sais pas.
- C'est une preuve de lumière,.
C'est à peu près temps diront
certains. Alors il annonce, ce
sont des mesures qui vont aider
beaucoup de femmes, en
particulier. Je pense que
c'était un des rares moments
rassembleurs qu'on a vus de
façon très, très clair.
- Et sur la justice criminelle,
peut-être.
- Il a très bien livré à ce
moment-là. Ça permet de faire un
petit commentaire juste à côté
de votre question qui dirait
essentiellement que la
construction de ce discours a
quand même été très habile.
Il a fait ces attaques
partisanes contre les
démocrates, mais il a pu
reverrait sur la question des
femmes et aussi, ça fait
maintenant 75 ans depuis la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale,
et le débarquement, et les
personnes qui étaient dans
l'audience. C'est créé une
émotion. En plus de cela, la
jeune fille qui avait, sur la
question du cancer, un projet
qui va donner de l'argent contre
le cancer pour les enfants,
comme tout cela ensemble, on
voit qu'il y en avait pour tout
le monde dans ce discours. C'est
pour cela que s'il y a une
fermeture dans une semaine, il
va avoir des fesses... soit il
part sa popularité d'un coup ou
comme vous avez dit tantôt, il
tweet demain matin.
- Je veux revenir sur le cancer
et la petite fille de 10 ans qui
étaient là. Elle avait recueilli
des fonds avant même d'avoir été
atteinte du cancer de cerveau.
Et lui annonce un programme de
500 millions de 10 ans pour les
enfants avec un cancer. C'est
quand même important.
- Et ça va être bien accueilli,
je crois. Évidemment, entre le
dire le faire... les discours de
l'union dans le passé, ce sont
de grandes listes d'épicerie.
Quand on fait le décompte
ensuite, un an ou deux ans plus
tard, dans bien des cas, le
pourcentage...
- Sur la santé, on veut protéger
les conditions existants.
- En même temps, cette habile.
Il se dit que s'il veut le mur,
il doit donner quelque chose aux
démocrates. Alors il a mis
plusieurs éléments que les
démocrates vont avoir de la
peine à laisser aller dans les
négociations.
- Ce n'est pas fini, on va en
parler John et Karine la pause.
Rester avec nous, Mesdames et
Messieurs, cette émission
spéciale sur le discours de
l'union de Donald Trump se
poursuit la pause.
- On sait que les États-Unis
allaient se retirer de façon
officielle du traité INF sur
les forces nucléaires de portée
intermédiaire.
(applaudissements)
nous n'avons vraiment pas le
choix. Est-il possible de
négocier un autre accord en
achetant la Chine et d'autres?
Peut-être, ce sera pas possible.
En quelques cas, nous avons
dépensé davantage que tous les
autres. Et cela, de loin.
- Alors est-ce que Donald
tremble bien de relancer la
course aux armements? John,
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez?
D'abord, course aux armements
c'est une chose, mais dépenser
plus, c'est une autre chose des
budgets. C'est inquiétant parce
que ça donne l'impression qu'il
n'y a pas de stratégie. Il se
retirait depuis, Monsieur
Poutine s'est retiré aussi. En
même temps, il y a une
négociation pour le libre-
échange avec la Chine, qui fait
consensus en termes de ses
objectifs, pour amener des
changements dans la façon que la
Chine transige avec les États-
Unis. Alors sur deux fronts, on
se demande ce que la stratégie.
Est-ce que l'homme est plus
important que l'autre? Est-ce
que la Chine va être prête à
négocier un traité pour limiter
les armements et le libre-
échange en même temps? Ça paraît
très compliqué et c'est ça qui a
été la grande critique la
semaine passée contre M. Trump.
Ce qu'il pose des gestes et on a
l'impression aussi qui ne
consulte pas les gens auprès de
lui. Je suis convaincu que les
forces armées, grands
commandants n'ont pas été dans
le coup. Même chose avec ses
commentaires sur d'autres
situations comme ISIS. Lui dit
que le groupe État islamique et
sur la fin, il le disait
quasiment.
- Un peu plus nuancée.
- Lorsqu'il a été question de
l'Iran, du fait qu'il a déchiré
l'accord avec l'Iran...
- Les démocrates n'ont pas dit
un mot. Mike Pompeo, le
secrétaire d'État s'est levé. Là
encore, on entre dans la partie
sonnerie et on sentait que les
gens faisaient, si vous me
permettez anglicisme, le tir les
dignes de M. Trump car le fond
des républicains, et il y a, il
y a eu une motion qui a été
passée au Sénat, qui a été
introduite par le leader
républicain sur la position d'un
retrait précipité d'Afghanistan
et de la Syrie. Donc, il n'y a
pas consensus.
- Sur l'Afghanistan, il a
affirmé que la paix s'imposait
après 18 ans. Il dit qu'on
négociait avec les talibans.
- Oui, bien ça fait plusieurs
années qu'on essaie de négocier
avec Dalida avec plus ou moins
de succès. On comprend que les
troupes américaines sont
fatiguées, que sur le terrain,
il n'y a pas d'avancée concrète,
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre ce
geste-là, c'est que le
leadership américain dans le
monde ne peut pas s'exprimer
uniquement par une augmentation
des budgets militaires. C'est un
leadership politique qui
disparaît justement en sortant
de l'accord. En tentant de
négocier à la pièce.
- Un leadership moral. Il
attaque les alliés comme l'OTAN
comme il a fait ce soir, disant
qu'on les a forcés à remettre
100 milliards. Il faut faire un
fact check sur ça.
- Je crois que déjà, ils disent
que c'est pas vrai.
- Il a tendance à aliéner ses
alliés et perdre l'autorité
quand il se toutes sortes
d'antan. Il n'a pas parlé
d'environnement ce soir.
Quand on parle de tous ces
retraits et avec les questions
des alliés, faire ton
leadership. Le monde est année
de l'Afghanistan. J'ai lu un
éditorial de New York Times,
tout l'éditorial c'était de
sortir de l'Afghanistan. Mais
pourquoi nous étions là il y a
18 ans, on va donner aux
talibans la possibilité de
donner ce qu'ils ont fait avant
la guerre.
- Il veut exercer son leadership
pour contrer le socialisme. Les
États-Unis ne sont jamais
socialistes et au fond, le
Venezuela est un bel exemple de
socialisme qu'il faut vaincre.
- Il y a consensus en Occident
sur la situation au Venezuela,
mais ça lui a servi de tremplin
pour lancer une petite pique aux
plus jeunes démocrates. Un gros
plan sur Saunders.
- Écoutant l'extrait.
- Chez nous, ici aux États-Unis,
nous sommes alarmés par ces
appels que l'on entend visant à
adopter le socialisme dans notre
pays.
(huées)
L'Amérique a été fondée sur la
liberté, l'indépendance, et non
la coercition des gouvernements,
domination et la prise de
contrôle. Nous sommes délivrés
nous allons demeurer libre.
(applaudissements)
- USA! USA!
USA! USA!
USA!
- Ce soir, nous renouvelons
cette détermination que
l'Amérique ne deviendra jamais
un pays socialiste.
(applaudissements)
- Alors, ça vit beaucoup de
monde ici.
- S'avise les démocrates. Le mot
socialiste, c'est un synonyme
pour dire les démocrates. Au
bout de la ligne, c'était
quasiment... probablement que
les gens hors caméra vont rire
de cela, M. Trump va peut-être
en rire. En plus de cela, il a
dit qu'il y aurait une guerre
majeure en Corée du Nord. Donc,
il est assez prévisible en
termes d'exagérer des choses et
il en a exagéré ce son.
- Apport la question des armes,
pas question de la Russie
vraiment dans ce discours.
Hound, ce son grand ami.
- Ils sont en amour.
- Très peu de substances dans
ces annonces de politique
étrangère. C'est des choses
qu'on savait déjà.
- On a pas appris grand-chose de
nouveau, sauf peut-être le congé
parental et des petites mesures
qui sauvent...
- Qui vont lui permettre de
gagner des points dans l'opinion
publique, comme disait John.
- Il a sauvé les meubles peut-
être ce soir car les quatre ou
cinq derniers mois, c'était
vraiment la déchéance.
- Un seul mot sur le Canada, ses
passions on a l'extrait et si on
a le temps de l'écouter. On a
plus le temps, mais...
- Il pose la ratification. Sur
ce point, on a tout intérêt
qu'il y ait une ratification ici
des gens vienne picoter sur
cette entente, ça risque d'être
les démocrates. Je pense que sur
ce point, on ne peut pas être
malheureux qu'il est fait de la
pression pour la ratification.
Qu'il est appelé l'ALÉNA
originale est une catastrophe,
ce sont des superlatifs à la
Trump.
- Somme toute, un discours
sobre, un bon discours...
- Je pense que pour 30, c'est un
bon discours. De faire appel à
la deuxième guerre mondiale et
Apollo 11, qui sont probablement
les deux événements les plus
rassembleurs des deux dernières
décennies semblent justement
donner le ton à ce discours. Et
si un discours à savoir
électoraliste.
- Je trouve qu'il était bien
construit dans son ensemble.
- Bien construit et bien écrit.
- Il a mieux livré. Il a
tendance des fois a mal livré
ses discours, même si c'est le
télé prompteur comme Christian
disait. Il n'a pas livré les
deux derniers qu'il a faits
durant le shutdown.
- I n'était pas aussi fâché
qu'on le pensait.
- Il souriait, il a commencé à
diriger les gens qui ont chanté
bonne fête à un vétéran.
Dans son ensemble, il a sauvé
les meubles ce soir. Il ne faut
pas le critiquer.
- On va en parler encore
longtemps, de Trump, pas de
discours, de 30.
Merci.
, Merci d'avoir suivi ce
discours spécial. Vous allez
retrouver de longs extraits de
ce discours demain et de son
impact. Bonne soirée et demain
19 heures pour 24/60.